hi guys inside has finally been released
if you didn't know inside is the new
game from the developers of limbo and I
don't know about you guys but I really
really enjoyed limbo it was really dark
had a great atmosphere and I'm expecting
really good things from inside I'll also
be live-streaming this so if I say
anyone's names run under me it's
bothering people in the livestream yeah
I love the art service and I love how
it's got color now because limbo was all
black
so cute when I saw it had color I was
like this is very strange because I'm
not used to Limbo having color no this
is limbo well it's kind of limbo but I
like it because it's not too much color
it's just kind of in some bits to make
you look Oh Adam
see that's the packs are being short
that's what I can do
cuz I'm short person okay so I'm not
gonna lie to you I have seen the old
Mike dot okay I think he's gonna run us
over I have seen the beginning obviously
didn't watch very well cuz we thought
they were about to run me over oh oh
bloody hell I was looking at the comment
this is gonna be so difficult
let's not let them see us this time did
they hear us yeah they did
let's go look at his spine he's back
profit goes up oh okay happy get
he doesn't hunch back please
can I like comes out don't do all our
backs do that when we bend over it scary
alright yeah that would have really hurt
if anyone else did that in real life
dogs I don't know anything about the
story though apart from that the story
is very good so I was watched a couple
episodes and I was like no I need to
play this game myself I can't can't be
watching other people play all the time
and this game is going to ruin dogs for
me whoa dogs are so cute but now these
ones like this is scrawny well you see
their nips on their bellies huh I
remember in limbo you always had to look
out for those traps on the floor but
because it was so done you can never see
them so you had to kind of remember
where they were you can kind of see them
a little bit and then just jump over
them I know what to do here and then go
back what
Oh No I don't know what oh no I know
it's a deer don't judge me
boom go this
yes I have no idea why they've got it
out for us so badly you did he do
something
he's obviously escaped that's the
obvious thing boom hi what do we do go
go go go go go
do you guys ever wonder how you would
fare in there in a chase you know
something like this how well would you
go in bloody hell but he's gonna get us
if he don't get us come on just fun you
can do this yeah I always think that
it's like my only motivation for staying
fit
oh my god it's okay oh god it's because
I'm scared that one day I'll be in a
situation like this and I won't be able
to get away what's that some paralyzing
dark isn't it they don't want to kill us
just want to curse the sleep but that's
still not good either
okay so pretty I love being underwater I
love something underwater because
everything's just so peaceful then you
come back up with you later oh it's the
world still here no I'm just I'm trying
to grab them so I could fold them over
along with me something away she can't
do that really another way John doesn't
know I just really like the the
animations of him he doesn't have a face
though you notice look at him doesn't
have any defining features
this is cool
you're gonna find some Aidan's those
money then sounds like money no tickets
no Justin you're so cute [ __ ] don't
know why sound effects like it cuz I did
oh do they think I'm their mom or dad
I think they do die the old chickens
he's facing the wrong way
woohoo okay he can leap so well wish I
can leap like that
hey can I let them in hey live chickens
that's a myth
come into my abode me and my kids
hi guys slender boy the faceless wonder
simulator
yep but he's not scary like Slenderman
he's not tall either and he's not
somewhere suit he's not as well dressed
what's this Oh a bit old and rusty Jim
yes
poor little dears are you okay you okay
are you okay
we killed one of our children it's
shelter all over again let's just yeah
let's just carry on we go for something
playing limbo was Muslim bow is short
game it's well then because I'm pretty
sure limber took me a little while to
complete some of the puzzles stumped me
this game is so detailed though in
comparison to limbo and to make me
shiver okay I've got twice re stuck in
my head they're sleeping and two potato
I don't think they're sleeping look
they've got worms growing out of them I
really don't think they're sleeping no
not good
it's pretty gross actually see see he's
not sleeping
actually you might have been stupid I
think you have a point there I think you
might mean visit Oh God
oh that was close dramatic music hey my
friend you poor thing
oh it's baby food himself Oh lovely do
you know what is that like massive
maggot or something because are you
forcing are you okay are you okay
pat pat pat the pig it's okay
it's out no you're okay come back here
oh poor thing right look this is so cool
this this is so cool
I've seen this before and I just think
this is freaking awesome this was this
is pretty much one of the reasons why I
was like no I have to play this game
myself because it's just too cool to not
play myself I need yeah okay
well haha when I leap we are in a
musical there's no this listening to
this missus new business I know anyway
am i doing all right let's go push this
thing do I need to push this manner I
pull this thing
okay they're not all right
thanks fellas you can control people
wearing hats by wearing hats so that's
the thing puffs from that no idea what's
going on your guess is as good as mine
not sure if they're dead
whoa you guys are saying those people
were dead you think they were dead I
thought they were under some sort of
trance or something like perhaps he was
because he's quite white you know he's
quite pale he could perhaps look dead so
yeah I thought maybe they were under
some sort of de France or perhaps
they've got like a chip in their brain
that's controlled by the heart baby it's
like the new form of concentration camp
or something using chips in their heads
do pigs have Minds pigs have minds I
mean they have brains is that the same
things in mind are you talking about age
of my thought processes
I don't think pigs have thought
processes I've had a pan it's only us
and dolphins that have thought processes
where do I go why don't I know all this
goosey hides the birds yeah halo 2 games
I'm trying to kill you oh you're not
chickens okay that's just carry on do
wear it I can hear them again um what am
i doing do I just jump down here guys do
you think I should jump down here do you
want to jump down there cuz if the thing
is at this game you can't go up and down
yeah I can't go forwards and backwards
if that makes sense I can't go that way
I can only go that way or that way oh oh
oh what's this no why am i doing that I
didn't there's something here
ah that should work
whoa.good
it's not like Mario then yo okay today
oh wait
this is dangerous don't deserve scared
don't fall with it let go oh my gosh
back before it went down okay let's go
down home
bye chicken oh I know they went here hey
this is cool what is it what is that
what was that well it was it's attached
by yellow wire to something huh I don't
think you were supposed I don't think
you had to do that either I thought I
think it was just an extra thing which
is cool glad I found it okay so that
doors open now
yeah both okay hey Dad oh my god oh I
thought some crushed him then he moved
out of the way I didn't think they could
move without me controlling them
mmm curious do you think he sees out of
the other people's eyes cuz he's acting
like he does
oh of course
today it was out you waiting for
I feel super now whatever
well it's gonna be super light because
he doesn't break a lot of stuff I wonder
if there's references to limbo I mean
it's all kind of simple oh he wasn't
supposed to survive that and I don't
blame him Oh oh good
so obviously it's just these people dead
or alive I think they're alive I know
some of you guys think they're dead
being controlled by an elitist group
perhaps cool that was close wasn't
oh my gosh who does you're not you're
not that lights young man the audio in
this game is spot-on
hey let's get on the pipe and then yeah
I'm scared it's just gonna jump down the
people need hugs you guys think that
everyone needs a hug sometimes you know
not everyone likes hugs I'm sorry to
break it to you but it's true and I
don't think these people are the hugging
type to be honest
you can try I'll let you try but I'm not
gonna do it where we going
hey little rat
oh my god he's dead
oh I'm dead oh not good can I go ah I
want to go in there
what's it I just go what do I do
okay oh god oh god
oh it's like the slither of black is so
tiny I wasn't even looking then I'm an
absolute idiot
haha stupid of robots you're not gonna
get me I'm too smart for you at least a
third time round I am at times a time
hey seagull there were so many seagulls
in my hometown it's gross because you
know seagulls are the only birds that
can actually who while they fly so
they're the ones you need to watch out
for when they fly above you oh my gosh
the harpy in my ear can you guess oh my
god
can you guys hear this I'm a real person
I'm not controlled because he's not even
you need to mimic their walking boy what
are you doing he's not even walking limp
keeps on looking back it not that I
could do much better I mean I'm not
saying oh god I'm not doing a very good
job of controlling him I don't know how
they don't already know that I'm a fake
I'm going to concentrate guys
ah that was so bad
I'm sorry Ida screamed for no reason I
know I'm an idiot yes
you put online so will I supposed to
jump or not
thank backwards and forwards
booyah freakin did a I am a clone
oh don't look at it don't look at it
you'll know that you have a
consciousness it's gone it's gone okay
we need to get out of here we need to
get out of here where do we go look at
that dog okay they're gonna find out
it's so obvious
I'm in red everyone else is in black and
brown and gray [ __ ] this let's go hey
guys hey oh wait are they real people
are they mannequins freaking out oh oh
yeah right don't whimper at me I'm not
gonna feel sorry for you and come back
thank you my good man
Oh hmm I need to have this box here so I
can get him to push the crate that but
then I need to be on the Box to get my
head than in this thing
ah ah look Lola I know what to do
because I can get on it here so leave it
there push the box back into place hey
yang clone
I think that would be horrendous as
there's too many of me no no one would
leave their house there'd be a lot of I
don't know there would be a lack of
common sense but book-smart to be there
let's get him into his home little hats
Merry Christmas I got you a person in a
box full of ice wanted and here's
matching helmet now you can control him
that is totally gonna be the future and
that's really scary hey have you noticed
that in games we just instinctively jump
because we just want to jump in the real
world we hardly ever jump I guess we
hide me everyone
ah okay oh my god no don't do that
woof we need to change this I was just
about to let go and then I realized that
my the actual boy would have just fell
implemented to his death
oh here we go yeah he can just do it
sweet so I can pull him to the road to
the next room yeah freaky is that a big
shock for when it opens up a shot
someone okay let's go we can hold our
breath we know this no oh
oh I forgot when we let go obviously
when I'm controlling him so he doesn't
hold it up and for us so we need to
actually be on the very edge you ready
for this guy's see if we can do this no
okay yeah get that submarine down there
those secrets underwater I imagine
that's where they'd be the tape keep
keep keep keep keep what's happened so
it's the press the button I don't feel
good about this it's a big glowing red
button where and what do I think it's
running from a group of people is trying
to control another group of people or
perhaps the rest of the world maybe they
put it under some some guys is that the
right word where they were like if you
inject this into yourself you'll become
all perfect and beautiful
maybe but something like that and if I
didn't actually it was a mind
controlling tool so they could mind
control them because us as humans were
pretty shallow we would definitely fall
for that
definitely
I don't think that dead though I really
don't think they're dead I just think
that under mind control Oh what did I
just do okay I wanted to go in that room
boom
yes made it that's good
whoa this is doc I think that's the
plains looking for us I don't know if we
should be seen no I don't know if we're
going to be seen so with the light this
is one massive suitcase is it a suitcase
because he could fit in it I could take
him on home bear with me me and little
inside kid going on holiday together
that would be adorable let's make this
happen
the Train
so they're kind of near civilization
then maybe it's something like that like
a science experiment center where they
don't oh my gosh is it trafficking like
human trafficking oh my god
no there's so many things that it could
be I mean whatever it is it's obviously
not legit because you could get out tell
people about it and they're obviously
not very happy about that
thanks for watching the first episode of
inside if you want to see more please do
let me know when I was live-streaming
this it went well for the first hour and
then started buffering so badly you can
see the full live stream in the live
streams uncut playlist I will try a nice
trim it again however if not I can still
just do another playthrough for you in
the video so give this a thumbs up if
you definitely want to see more of it
you also want to hear your theories
about what you think is happening in
inside I think a lot of you might know
the anything else no spoilers no
spoilers hello is everything fine what
oh no oh no
what's this what does that mean wait ah
we only have three jobs